the Joe Rogan experience gentleman looks
you ready we're here yeah that's her
this years sober October physical
challenge like you're presenting it like
a [ __ ] but presidential candidate
it's like an apple when I win it's gonna
be good
hip-hop dance let me soft sell you let
me solve some okay we each get a
choreographer and we work dance classes
as much as we can dance classes are
pretty aggressively leave it to the
audience to vote here listen to hear me
out
when what I like that idea Joe we can do
that now hear me out
sorry each my first of October right
that's what you're doing a pitch you
make him think it was their idea yeah
look over at that belt you're never
getting that but hold on hold on was
like oh guys hear me out
everyone listen to me are you sure he's
putting the baggage belt on oh okay all
right I haven't even touched this thing
since October hey was made with any sort
of belt man we go to dance classes to
get our skill set up we each work with a
choreographer to create our own dance to
the exact same song at the end at the
end at the end by the way I'm selling
this to the room yeah threading that
through your jeans at the end of the
eyeball template melts onto if at the
end of the month come November first we
each submit our one-minute hip-hop dance
choreographer choreography video and the
fans vote on who the winner of sober
October is gentlemen I would like to
hear your bottles starting with Tom
Segura I got to tell you watchin this
your rebuttals okay punk : yeah you put
you start imagine that here's what I'll
tell you what I like about it it's easy
to say what I don't like about anything
that comes out of your mouth yeah so
what I don't like about it or what I do
like about it is that no one's great at
it
I do like sure that it is a workout
because those dancers are an
unbelievable what do you think there's
not one dancer right now me obviously
first Joe second it's not even close
what are you talking about it's
definitely me what I'm Way better dancer
than you guys he out of your [ __ ] mind
do you know dance no but I know I'm
better dancer than you guys listen I
could do a lot of crazy [ __ ] with my
body you guys can't do that's true but
I'm saying rhythm you have rhythm yes
all right
hold on you have rhythm I know I do I'm
[ __ ] phenomenal at dancing but no no
you get the club saying is that nobody
excels I mean I always am better than
you but nobody excels so I like the idea
of working at something that you know no
one's great at and dancing movie I was
in the movie zookeeper yeah I took dance
classes oh all right a dance my ass off
[ __ ] I love all the movies make it seem
normal that that guy could get that girl
I know okay well yes like legitimately I
mean I'm not good or any Cho this is
hip-hop dance we're talking about son oh
yeah you do pretty good there actually
you're right I took [ __ ] dance
lessons I did do it for weeks
oh you dance with Nikki Glaser Leslie
Bibb she's from Talladega Nights yeah
yeah she's great she's great right
person - that sounds like a done deal
there's mathletes the last thing that is
great okay so everybody gets to work at
it nobody excels too much at it I think
it's funny that we're comics and we get
to look silly doing something yeah I do
not look great at it and I'm on board
with I think it's fun that people that
watch that or get really into it would
have a say in it okay I'm the only one
of the three of us who's not obese so it
would look lovely silly for me
doing I'm medically obese I think that's
okay sorry about the BMI son yeah it's
all about the BMI might be an eyes off
the tree you're saying that you are in
do it or not I'm saying I would look at
least silly just in terms of that but
you guys I get why you look silly just
moving at all hmm we also need your
silly no I'm not I'm not a [ __ ] fact
to make yourself always you're always
breaking yeah break yourself before you
break ankles and elbows and shake your
own breaking I am breaking stuff that's
kid super [ __ ] vulnerable I am it's
good point without injury what's injury
no no dance classes are intense do you
really think you're the current best
answer easily I think yeah I definitely
most out of all of us
I agree dance classes are tough we get
each get ourselves choreographers yeah
and we create our own dance to the exact
wait wait wait for me to talk about this
okay but the amount of Molly I would
have to do to enjoy that dancing but you
can't be sober but you can November
first that when we post ideas the dance
sober
here's here's problems with it number
one it's subjective you can't have
something subjective you can't have so
the whole thing Tom dance better wrong
thing or dance better can't have a bunch
of morons vote for okay okay let me let
me break this down finish up what if
what if what if the dance pros got
together that's what I was saying
professional sweat great judge well yeah
they're better they like me better you
don't want that judges they literally go
to jail but so we have to agree no
bribing me I can bribe Olympic judges
no no nothing subjective we got a grind